all right in our special series school
matters we are looking at the debates
over how to reopen schools safely
and handle remote learning during the
pandemic today
we're focusing on how some parents are
creating an alternative type of class
called
learning pods they are now hiring a
teacher or aid to educate their kids
in a small group adriana diaz shows us
why some people believe this type of
learning
will increase education inequality
we don't have it all figured out but
rolling with it i guess in walnut creek
california
business owners amanda pinkham and
wilson stevens are preparing their son
for a new school year
but at school like you've never seen it
walker will start second grade in a
learning pod
when pinken was looking for families to
partner with the response was
overwhelming
people just left and right saying can
you include me can you email me can i be
a part of your conversation
so that would be the positives if we
could work that out
she agreed to a pod with four families
from nearby they recently met up for the
first time to figure out how
the pod will work what if they stayed
social distance and broke up into
different
groups pinkham says students will follow
the local public school district's
curriculum
online a higher teaching assistant will
work with the kids in person
five days a week the learning will take
place outside
and when the weather is bad they'll
rotate between students homes
when inside students will wear masks the
cost
seven hundred to a thousand dollars a
month per
family i find myself wondering barbara
do some parents not know really what
they're getting themselves into
you know i saw a great meme that said
you lied to me my child is not a
pleasure to have in class
barbara mckeon is a lifelong educator
who runs a national development program
for principals
i see it as a really strong opportunity
but i also
have some reservations about it those
reservations
really have to do with equity what
happens to students who are homeless
what happens to students with
disabilities
what happens to english language
learners many families simply can't
afford the high price of a pod
not only for the 16.2 percent of
children who live below the poverty line
but even middle class families without
deep pockets
there you go yay genesis emory's
five-year-old son noah
a special needs student is about to
start kindergarten
she wishes she and others could afford
pods
i think as a country we should try to
put something in place where that all
students have access to the same thing
whether you're a public school student a
private school student a charter school
student
should we be looking at a model where
school districts themselves get together
and create
pods so that everyone has access to them
i think we should be looking at as many
models as possible
pinkham agrees pods are not the perfect
solution but says it's the best one they
have
we're all trying to figure out what's
best for our family i definitely
feel lucky and blessed that we're in a
position to be able to
look at doing this and i have multiple
times
said i just can't imagine what people
are going through that aren't in that
position
so i'm conscious of that
there really is no standard for how pods
are run some people are hiring certified
teachers others are hiring two
tutors and some parents are trying to do
it themselves without having to pay
anyone
educators do worry though that these
different approaches will create
a patchwork system that could have
long-term effects on education
but for the parents we spoke to who can
do this they're just happy to have some
sort of solution
gail yeah the pods idea seems like it
could work but it also is very pricey
thank you very much adriana everybody's
still trying to figure this out